leaving football it's nearly two years
of this anis two years G so M was you
missed the game but it must be kind of a
relief as well to to just not have that
regime I wouldn't say it's a relief
because I've you know I was very lucky
to have a career that lasted for 22
years you know and I played for some of
the best clubs in the world I played
with some of the best players and under
the best managers in the world so I had
a I had a very long career but you know
I wouldn't say it's a really if it just
I knew it was the right time to finish
no days have you what sorry don't know
what no days like in the last two years
like after the first six months he went
maybe I'll go back late any days you
woke up a lot um then the day after I
literally was like questioning myself
wherever I'd made the right decision and
then every time even now you know every
time that I go to a big sporting event
or watch England play you know I loved
playing for all the clubs that I played
with over the years but the one thing
that I miss more than anything is
playing it playing for England it's one
of the things that I was most proud of
being given the England armband and
being able to cap to my country for the
amount of time that I did you know it's
the one thing that I miss out a football
that really kind of every not every
single day but every time England come
around for their games and every time
they go into a big competition it's one
thing that I really kind of really kind
of gets to meet you
but if Norwich City came back to you now
yeah he is poised
you are you are still involved in
football because of course the boys all
play yes they do and which must be weird
pressure on them that they're all very
good I'm sure like one is in Brooklyn
he's now Brooklyn Romeo and Cruz they're
all at the Arsenal Academy yeah and they
know he's got a bigger didn't this is
mean didn't you ref one of the matches
yet for Romeo Romeo was playing in the
game and Romeo is that he's the most
emotional out of all of the all of the
kids actually so yeah you know I could
say no to him and he's bottom lip goes
so he was playing this game and the
referee hadn't turned up so all the
parents were looking at me as if to say
man so I went onto the pitch and a side
referee in the game it was going great
they were winning for Neil and then one
of the opposition players went through
towards our goal I shouldn't say
and Ramya went to make a tackle and he
missed the ball and took the player down
so it was an obvious penalty and I'm
thinking ah I really don't want to make
this decision but then I look at our
parents and they're like and then I look
at the other parents in their life I
know I had to give the penalty so I give
the penalty and Romeo's looking at me
and I can see he's like eyes are welling
up I can see his bottom lips going and
the kid and so the kid stepped up took
the penalty
I shouldn't say thankfully but he missed
it and uh and as they're as our team
were breaking as Romeo's team was
breaking he ran past me said I can't
believe you did that
I usually take pictures with all the
fans and then I felt like this wasn't
you know yeah it's not appropriate right
no I'm comfortable timing as well
because I was actually going to South
Africa at the time with England and I
ended up meeting Nelson Mandela I know
you